this job try saves many people as we can  sometimes that doesn't mean everybody  but you don't give up  New York Washington DC circle via  okay that's enough captain people are  afraid  that's why I'm here  we need be put in check whatever form  that takes I'm game  I'm sorry Tony if I see a situation  pointed South I can't ignore it times I  wish I could sometimes I want to punch  you in your perfect teeth I know we're  not perfect  but the safest hands are still our own  Wow  I was wrong about you the whole world  was wrong about you they're coming for  you I'm not the one that needs to watch  their back  this doesn't have to end in a fight Tony  you just started a war  stay down final warning I could do this  all day  all right I've run out of patience  underoos hey everyone  and no supervision that's something the  world can no longer tolerate I know how  much Bucky means you